un ouvrier est-allemand pas sur mars ou
à celui de l'ouest pour la première fois
ouest et laisse travailler ensemble
après le mur de berlin c'est aujourd'hui
un rideau de fer que ça soit les
allemands de l'est j'ai pas d'airé aux
particules east français en référence à
ce qui se passait là bas
la liberté staline n'a jamais été notre
idéal communiste alors même nom mais qui
vous ont précédés aubry mais vous me
posez la question à mort
le parti communiste français a été le
parti qui s'est battu contre les guerres
coloniales notre histoire à la tout
sépare de lumière et ses parts d'ombré
on a beaucoup qu'il change d'étiquettes
dès qu'ils ont une affaire au cul c'est
pas notre cas nous on assume